[Music]
so the subject for today is fertility
fertility of the truth but but in order
to understand why we are here we also
need to understand where we come from
and and you received the Prize in
Economics back in 2001 and at that time
you were very active in the discussion
already back then in discussion about
globalization you wrote a book in 2002
on globalization and the disc contents
so can you just take us back for a
moment to that discussion and and and
let's see if there is a link to what you
identified back then and the rise of
populism and the kind of politics that
we are now in yeah I think there is a is
a link one of the problems is that some
of our political leaders oversold
globalization they said that everybody
was going to be better off as a result
of globalization it didn't happen and in
fact standards of living of many people
got worse to the point just in the
United States the median income of a
full-time male worker and the ones who
have full-time jobs are the lucky ones
of a full-time male worker in the United
States are what the look at the level
that they were some 42 years ago and the
real wages at the bottom are the same
level that there were 60 years ago so
the fact that they are doing very badly
is unambiguous and they were told that
they perceived some of that as a result
of globalization there are other forces
like technology but globalization did
play a role and the fact that it did
play a role means that if you have
people demagogues like Trump so much
easier to blame others for your problems
then saying we didn't do enough to help
people adapt to the
in technology we didn't do enough to
help those people who were facing stress
and so that's been where the the
dialogue went it was to blame others and
this is how it fits into our discussion
today the fact that what the political
leaders said was not correct it was not
true
was not true undermined trust not in
only in those political leaders but in
the elites and the institutions of the
leaks that seem to support that but they
thought they were doing the right thing
or are you suggesting that they did it
with the knowledge that it would hurt
our societies that's a good question
there were some of us that were raising
questions about what globalization was
going to do to inequality and for the
most part I think I was in the Clinton
administration when some of these bad
trade agreements were done and I don't
think that anybody thought they were
going to have the magnitude of the
adverse effects that they did but we
were aware that there was a problem and
we advocated what was called Trade
Adjustment Assistance we we realized
that people were going to lose their
jobs and we argued that there needed to
be assistance but the Republicans
consistently pushed back on that so bad
so that was the main problem you think
with the policies that we're not dealing
with the adverse adverse consequences of
a free trade or what was what was what
was really the problem if you would've
seen that I mean what I'm saying the
people who were losing the jobs were the
people who were the obvious sources you
know they were feeling at front on but
the the broader problem was that as we
open up our markets
we put unskilled American workers in
competition with unskilled workers from
developing countries from China and
economic science if you want to use that
word economic science predicted that in
that context wages of unskilled workers
in the United States will go down so we
knew that there were going to be these
adverse effects and this is where there
was some dishonesty even though
everybody should have known it the
political leaders ignored it and most
economists particularly in the policy
sphere wanted to be on the on the train
that was moving and so their view was
well somehow the economy will grow as a
result and the benefits somehow will
trickle-down theory did not have any
evidence theory to support that but if
there was I think in there's a little
bit of of praying hoping and and a
little bit of dishonesty so so what
would have been the right policy at the
time if you take us back 15 years when
this discussion was very much alive and
we see we saw movements also here in
Europe the the attack movement that was
I mean physically attacking the
politicians that were in favor of
globalization not least here in in
Gothenburg in 2001 sure so so it would
have entailed a new social contract
where in a way you know Sweden has
managed this in this net scant Nordic
countries have managed is better than
almost anywhere where else because you
had to be open you're a small country it
would be inconceivable that you would
close your your borders but to remain
open and not to have a strong political
backlash you had to have some social
contract of shared prosperity some
degree of shared prosperity
so that is the kind of framework that
that when needed there are different
ways of getting out but that's what
should have happened in the United
States but didn't happen so but it was
worse than that one of the more
contentious provisions of the recent
trade negotiations TTIP the trade
between United States and and Europe was
the investment agreements and and tanks
a thousands of people turned out against
that the object of those investment
agreements is to give working worsen
bargaining rights of workers and each
country what they did is to give invest
American firms say investing abroad more
property rikes abroad than they had in
the United States and the same
symetrically was true in Europe now why
would you want to do that why would
countries with strong property rights
one of the big advantages that we had as
a country is our strong system the rule
of law and property rights why would we
want Vietnam to have as strong
protection as the United States well
very simple it meant that American
corporations could go to their workers
and say if you don't take a wage cut
we're going to move our factory to
Vietnam and em Vietnam we're going to be
protected by a Mirabeau tree a treaty
and get more property rights than we
have in the United States what do I mean
by that
you know an example is we're talking
about climate change if you change a
regulation in the United States or in
Europe that would require a firm to
reduce its carbon emissions it can't sue
the government and say oh you're hurting
my profits but under the trade
agreements if you change the legal
regulatory framework and profits go down
the company can sue the government sue
the government for a regulation to
protect the world or to protect hell
with our safety and this is not a
hypothetical you know this is not a
hypothetical possibility Philip Morris
sued the org Wayne government for
regulations that it imposed saying you
had to disclose that cigarettes are bad
for your health and they have plain
wrapper and the problem was these
packaging regulations reduce the demand
for cigarettes hurt Philip Morris's
profits and Philip Morris under these
provisions sued the org weighing
government to compensate itself for the
loss of profits so in other words the
these trade agreements say the right to
kill is more important or the right to
profit is more important than the right
to life so you see that the the the
effects of the system that it was
basically rigged in favor of some US
corporations exactly but but but here in
Europe oh and European corporations yeah
I'm doing but if you don't look at if
you look at incomes for example you talk
about stagnating incomes in the US for
the middle class for four decades now
but if you look at a country like Sweden
we have had income growths four broad
groups now for the last twenty five
years and still populism is on the rise
here as well well part of the things if
you look at Europe as a whole the the
middle class has not been doing well I
mean Sweden is doing better than other
countries but the inequality has been
growing in sweeps the incomes are going
up but incomes are going up but in other
countries that's not true where is not
as true so it is not a surprise to me
that people in Sweden looking around the
global landscape say we're protected now
but how do we know the future you know
this is a you might say a social
contract but a contract so the fear is
true I think there is a real and unless
you really you know
it's real it's real it's it's oh I think
there is a reason to fear the future I
think there's a reason to fear the
future unless you get institutions that
really are committed to protecting and
this is where you see some of the
controversy going on so for instance the
head of the ECB Draghi at one point made
an onslaught a criticism on criticism of
welfare stakes interesting thing there
has never been a crisis caused by a
country with too big of a welfare state
there has been a phonetic a crisis
caused by too big of a financial sector
in an under regulated financial sector
and yet you know it's always a strategy
rather than talking he's supposed to be
running the financial system rather than
talking about the failures to regulate
the financial system let's turn to talk
about the failures the welfare stay well
it's not perfect but there's never been
a crisis caused by the welfare state so
the point is there has been an attack on
the welfare state and if I were worker
in one of the well first you know stakes
you worry if that attack is successful
in the way the trumpism has been
successful my security is undermined but
still in this country the welfare state
is alive and kicking exactly yeah you
were one of the few okay the Nordic
region at least so if you're a
politician now and and and you really
you care about the future of the liberal
democracy about science respect for
academic evidence facts how do you deal
with this situation well if you're in
this region the Nordic you you it's you
have an advantage because you can see
what's happening the United States and
you can say that's not for us yeah you
see a failed experiment and and a
divided society and and you say that's
not the way we want a girl woke walk
this way don't go that way and
and to say what we've learned from that
experiment is a dividing society gets
more and more divided you get more and
more money in politics which is one of
the important lessons for democracies
keep money out of politics make sure you
support these institutions of
truth-telling and while they well among
them are the press and one of the things
that one of the concerns is that the way
the press was supported the business
model of the press has always been a
fragile business model it required
advertising was not obvious that these
marrying advertising and truth was a
good marriage and it had some problems
but it worked for a long time but now
it's not working because the social
media Google Facebook have drained all
the advertising revenues and one has to
recognize that the press an important
Free Press is a key institution in our
democracy is what I call a public good
and therefore has to be supported so the
you know TV Swedish TV is one of the few
institutions of press around the world
in which there's confidence and trust
and and you may find that yeah I don't
know it's still high but it's going it
has been going down for all big media
companies not only in in the US but
around the Western world you see that in
the surveys that are being conducted so
so I guess what I'm saying is one has to
realize that he's going to need a strong
public support for a free press and you
mean money money yeah money by the
government by government support public
support and it's a public good our
society cannot function without the
check and check makes it part of the
system checks and balance of a free
press and it can oppress be free if it's
supported with government money yes and
that was exactly what I was going to say
sorry yeah that just like I said these
things - it could be abused government
presses are in authoritarian regimes are
used to bolster that but in the UK a
free press works and so you you you have
to create institutions of oversight
civic participation and one of the
developments of a gas a glass half
century is the growth of civil society
institutions so I think we're actually
in a better place to make institutions
like a active Free Press and including
TV viable in countries some countries
educated free press this is such an
important part of our societies and for
democracy why is there is the crisis in
confidence among among parts at least
parts of society don't don't trust these
institutions well I mean you know you're
part of a global society
and in large parts of this global
society the press has not earned our
trust and that goes back to what I said
if you have newspapers owned by Rupert
Murdoch who see the press as a way of
advancing their ideological positions
lowering taxes entertainment but not
fact-based not toothpaste then of course
that's gonna lose trust and so and and
and this goes also back to the notion
that Liars have an easier time than
truth tellers all our institutions are
fallible and make mistakes and the
problem is that the Liars are very good
at exposing the mistakes of those who
are trying to tell the truth and
occasionally falter it's that in you
know know people well
the magnitude you know of somebody like
Rupert Murdoch and being able to wage
attacks you know we have in the United
States basically two national papers New
York Times in The Wall Street Journal
and he owns one of those two and so he
has a vehicle for advancing a big
platform he also controls Fox News one
of the major TV stations and it's
absolutely clear there's been actually
good research showing how Fox News has
affected people's beliefs and how they
vote and that's consequences so the
bottom line of all this is when you have
media whose agenda is not truth-telling
but advancing a profits or advancing an
ideological position you're going to get
a deterioration of the truth that
confident that raises the question that
you you mentioned before how does a
liberal democracy deal with that kind of
problem without becoming an illiberal
democracy yeah that is really the
challenge how do you not go into the
abuses as you try to protect yourself
and here you know I
we focused before on one of the
institutions the truth tell me which is
a free press there are others science
institutions of science our institutions
of higher learning are also important
institutions and so you know one of the
things that as institutions education
more important than sort of filming
people's brains with particular
knowledge is helping them understand the
distinction between what is true and
what is not what we mean by the science
so I think we have to do a better job in
and enhancing their ability of our
citizens to differentiate between truth
and non truth and if we do a better job
they they will respond I mean I again I
think one of the optimistic in this
respect well one of the problems in the
United States is for the past third of a
century there's been an assault on
public institutions including education
and so there's been a defunding of
education if you look at what are called
the Pisa scores these are score there
are standardized tests given across
countries and United States where the
you know one of the richest countries
performs really mediocre you know and so
we you know it's been a 30-year assault
on our education institutions
undermining the ability of large
fractions of Americans to make those
critical unfortunately we Swedes can't
brag about our results either so that's
the privatization of your education
system yeah there isn't there is a big
discussion about that here right now
there should be let me just return you
you mentioned two companies and and we
have a couple of minutes left and let's
spend the time on them because they play
such a huge role right now in our
globalized digitalized society and
that's Facebook and Google that's right
are they a problem or a solution no I
think they're they're a problem they
could be part of the solution but right
now
their incentives are not focused on
being part of the solution their
incentives are to maintain their profits
and so you know they have lots and lots
of data they know more than we do about
what is going on you know did it really
take a year to find out that Russians
Russia we're polluting the campaign and
sending messages out to more than half
of Americans now ya know we they knew
that right away but it was not in their
incentive
to disclose it until it was very clear
probably that our secret agents the CIA
or somebody else would disclose it
because they didn't want the criticism
that would follow from that so well
they've constantly been saying is yes
there's a problem but government's not
the solution and it goes back a little
bit back this spirit is a little bit
back to when we had all the
controversies about textile
manufacturers abusing human rights in
and they said oh yes but there's a
problem but we've it to us don't do any
regulation because that'll make things
even worse and so that is the image that
they're trying to do trust but trust us
because you can't trust the government
but at the same time they are not
willing to so the problem of fake news
for example they don't view themselves
as as media companies that's right they
do so so clearly something if something
has to happen and they are other they're
either
there should be pressed to do it with
regulation or or what should be done
well I think they have to be regulated
in what in what way so well who do you
recommend and got a government liberal
and liberal democratic government to do
and not becoming a liberal yeah so I
don't worry about Sweden becoming a
liberal yet so if and let me be there
are some easy things and there's some
more difficult things so some of the
easy things are disclosure requirements
you know if you have a paid
advertisement you have to know who is
paying you and disclose that when that
message has been circulated so you would
then know and when Americans are getting
a message paid by a Russian or Russian
bond they would know where it's
companies II check exactly that would be
very easy
you could have systems of verification
you know if you make an assertion you
could have
of institutions that verify young you
would say this has been verified this
has not been verified this has been
falsified so that kind of information
you can slow down the speed with which
information gets transmitted so that you
don't get these cascades the mafiocracy
that I talked about there locks you know
that the whole thing is how you trend
and that is how you man
manipulate the media so you the the
whole framework so you can slow that
down if you slowed it down by just a
little bit and McCrone did that during
the the frank selection that that worked
so there's a whole variety of things
that in the PowerPoint that didn't have
a chance to present where I align things
that would do not represent in any way a
threat to it can't be done that can't be
done but there are stronger things if
they won't do it there is a sense that
this is a public utility what we call
the public utility is something that is
a platform over which this is what you
have to operate and everybody and public
utilities probably should be if they
can't be well regulated need to be
publicly owned so I think that
public ownership has been obviously
Facebook has an incentive to try to tell
you that public ownership won't work and
they've been remarkably successful in
that kind of propaganda but I think
there's absolutely no today the
technology was publicly developed I
think there are systems of checks and
balances that would make a public
utility work professor Stiglitz thank
you very much indeed for a fascinating
conversation thank you
thank you good